toi
non
bonsoir les gueules noires ont surgi et
rugit de nouveau à bucarest en roumanie
plusieurs milliers de mineurs en grève
et en colère ont manifesté pour exiger
une augmentation de salaire à leur
manière c'est-à-dire à coups de barres
de fer ils ont même réussi à envahir le
ciel du gouvernement hellène francs dont
des cocktails molotov des matraques des
barres de fer
les mineurs qui se sont lancés à
l'attaqué du siège du gouvernement
roumain était bien armé de plus ils
étaient venus en force près de 4000 au
total et les 300 policiers munis de
grenades lacrymogènes
non pas si longtemps le point les
gueules noires ont brisé la porte et les
vitres du siège du gouvernement
et puis ils sont entrés à l'intérieur du
bâtiment un bâtiment qui symbolise
l'homme à battre et romane le premier
ministre les mineurs réclament sa
démission
ils le tiennent pour responsables de
leurs faibles salaires et de leurs
mauvaises conditions de vie déjà ce
matin il était arrivé en gare de
bucarest hawk ride
il y à jouer romane dans la mine à bas
les profiteurs
ils arrivée massive à bord de trains
voler dans des gares saccagé en guise de
réponse le gouvernement a mobilisé
toutes les forces de police
mais les mineurs lente averti rien ne
nous arrêtera ses gueules noires avait
rendu un grand service aux dirigeants
roumains l'année dernière en
pourchassant les partisans d'une plus
grande démocratie mais il se retourne
aujourd'hui contre leur protecteur très
nombreux et très organisés ces mineurs
qui semble sortir d'une autre époque
sont capables on le sait d'une grande
violence car de noir du président ignace
coup en juin 90 il avait tué et blessé
des dizaines d'opposants
aujourd'hui c'est donc contre ce même
pouvoir qu'ils se révoltent
pascal verdot l'histoire bégaie en
roumanie mais toujours dans les
violences en juin 90 les gueules noires
de la vallée de l'alzou fer de lance du
front de salut national sèment la
terreur dans les rues de bucarest chasse
au volant les voyous hostile aux
communistes chasse aux intellectuels de
l'opposition chasse aux tsiganes pétré
romane premier ministre affirme que les
mineurs sont venus spontanément pour
lutter contre les fascistes qui veulent
renverser le régime
tradition de violence tradition de mini
ouvrière pourtant choyé il y a un an
encore par le gouvernement les salaires
bloqués sous ceausescu augmente de plus
de 30% la retraite passe de 50 à 45 ans
mais surtout en deux jours les mineurs
deviennent une véritable force politique
la crise économique
le passage douloureux à l'économie de
marché symbolisée par pétré romane
signifie paupérisation insupportable
disent les mineurs qui réclament leur dû
les paras français de nouveau à kolwezi
mais pour une opération secteur
humanitaire
leur mission consiste à évacuer tous les
ressortissants français et étrangers
menacés par les soldats zaïrois rebelles
et depuis hier c'est à dire depuis
l'arrivée des troupes françaises dans la
capitale zaïroise nos calme est revenu
mais la situation reste très tendue et
le bilan de ces deux jours d'émeutes et
considérable voici les premières images
de kinshasa commentée par morad aït
habbouche
scènes de pillages dans le quartier
commercial de la capitale
tout le monde se serre militaires hommes
femmes et enfants
chacun se débrouille pour emporter son
butin tous les moyens sont bons dans les
rues la police a disparu
les militaires rebelles règne en maître
à leur tête selon des témoins des
colonels et des généraux de l'armée
visite guidée dans la ville hier matin
kinshasa ville fantôme les dégâts sont
considérables
plus loin là où les militaires français
ou belges ont pris position le calme est
revenu
des centaines de ressortissants
européens ont réussi à être évacués sur
brazzaville
il reste sous le choc il s'en passe au
dessus ils sont passés par n'importe où
ils sont retrouvés à peu près difficile
de dire 250 300 300 personnes à qui on a
dit tout de suite
prenez tous nous fait pas de mal mais
prenez tout prenez tout ce que vous
voulez et tout est à vous c'est cette
offre ça dépasse tout entendement
je te contentes et à brazzaville
absolument nous sommes en sécurité ici
le président mobutu qui avait disparu
ces derniers jours est apparu à la
télévision il a mis en garde les
rebelles et a parlé de manipulation
politique dernier bilan une vingtaine de
morts mille deux cent cinquante blessés
selon médecins sans frontières
ce soir à kinshasa la situation est
toujours confuse l'économie du pays déjà
exsangue est plus que catastrophique et
la disette menace les experts de l'onu
qui se trouve à bagdad deviendront-ils
les otages de saddam hussein ils sont en
effet toujours bloqués dans la capitale
irakienne
saddam hussein ne les libérera que s'il
récupère tous les documents portant sur
sa politique nucléaire
les états unis n'aient preuve ne prévoit
pas de représailles du moins pour
l'instant mais on déployait en arabie
saoudite de nouvelles batteries de
défense antimissile patriot un nouvel
espoir en yougoslavie les présidents
serbe et croate qui sont rencontrés et
ont promis de respecter totalement le
cessez-le-feu mais l'un et l'autre
devront compter avec leurs extrémistes
qui rêvent d'en découdre par exemple en
croatie
on le sait depuis le
début des affrontements des milices
d'extrême droite croates ont en effet
fait leur apparition et elles occupent
des positions stratégiques entre serbes
et croates
la guerre a donc réveillé dans cette
région une histoire que beaucoup
auraient voulu oublier à jamais nos
envoyés spéciaux ont rencontré ces
nostalgiques de la seconde guerre
mondiale rapporte à jean françois
grégoire patrick mille herriot et jean
françois mallet sur les hauteurs de
zagreb 2000 personnes sont venues se
recueillir devant la dépouille dans tes
paradzik numéro deux du parti froide du
droit d'extrême droite
c'est le deuxième compagnons d'armes
rencontré dans les prisons communiste
que père de brosses lavent parraga
président du parti mais cette fois c'est
un officier croate qui a abattu le
militant extrémiste
lors d'un contrôle je sens que mon fils
président est un homme des services
secrets je sais bien que ce sont des
gens des forces du ministère de
l'intérieur en uniforme de police qui
ont tiré avec leur arme automatique de
la tension est vive entre le
gouvernement croate et ce mouvement
d'extrême droite qui refuse de se
soumettre lundi
on a frôlé l'affrontement inter croate
lorsque des gardes nationaux sont venus
prendre le contrôle autour d'une caserne
fédéral harcelée depuis jours par les
miliciens de parraga ailleurs en croatie
les dix mille âmes de sept milices
rebelles refusent en bloc tout cessez le
feu
le parti croate du droit est l'héritier
du dictateur en tp bellic et des
oustachis croates pro-nazis auteurs de
massacres sur les serbes leurs opposants
affirment qu'en 50 ans ils n'ont pas
changé
v notre parti en 1861 bien avant
qu'apparaissent l'idéologie fasciste en
europe
maintenant nous avons toujours la même
idéologie l'indépendance de la croatie
ne sommes ni fasciste ni communiste
faisant preuve d'un nationalisme
démesurée le parti d'extrême droite
revendique ni plus ni moins les trois
quarts de la yougoslavie
la guerre est la principale motivation
de ses hommes
ils feront tout pour qu'elle dure leur
détermination sur le terrain oblige
zagreb à les tolérer
mais une montée en puissance de cette
armée parallèle risque de menacer à
terme la cohésion de l'ensemble des
forces croates en france est toujours le
feuilleton argent et politique qui tient
la une des journaux celle du canard
enchaîné aujourd'hui qui épingle cette
fois les centristes il se serait servi
un jeu aussi aux rayons des supermarchés
ces pressions politiques pour
l'implantation des supermarchés met en
cause plusieurs personnalités du cds
notamment dans la manche et à reims des
pratiques frauduleuses qui n'inquiète
apparemment pas les dirigeants
centristes ce soir ils se disent sereins
même s'il ne démentent pas
jean baptiste préavis et raymond sarde
avait fait galerie commerciale anodine
de cherbourg est au centre de la sphère
du jour selon le canard enchaîné en
novembre 86 son installation aurait été
chaudement recommandé par un responsable
cds à un sénateur lui aussi cds membre
de la commission nationale d'urbanisme
commercial depuis 73 les ouvertures des
grandes surfaces doivent être approuvées
par des commissions départementales et
en cas de recours par une commission
nationale des élus participent à chaque
niveau avec un risque de pots de vin
voire de financement occulte de partis
politiques je ne connais pas beaucoup
dans scènes de distribution qui peut se
targuer d'être passés en dehors des
mailles du système tout notre jeu
aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer d'avoir le
moins à payer et dans des formes ou
c'est le moins répréhensibles alors vous
savez quand ces cent mille francs et 6
200 mille francs par la 500 mille francs
pour des investissements de l'ordre de
220 230 millions quelquefois on s'estime
bien
rome aux cds mise en cause pour la
période 86 88
on estime que les documents publiés ne
prouve rien et on plaide la surprise jeu
j'ai appris des choses que j'ignorais ce
sera pour les grandes surfaces à projet
de loi est à l'étude
il vise à renforcer la transparence et
devrait être discuté cet automne au
parlement
côté politique en attendant chacun
continue de régler ses comptes
précisément ces affaires qui égrène
l'actualité explique en grande partie la
morosité qui envahit le monde politique
à gauche comme à droite
et pour lutter contre ce mal contagieux
chaque camp choisissons remontant pour
edith cresson qui a planché devant les
parlementaires socialistes
la médication a un nom solidarité edith
cresson qui a voulu passer en revue tout
son programme de gouvernement au moment
où beaucoup l'a10 dans une mauvaise
passe
1h15 pour une intervention que certains
ont qualifié de discours programme beef
daniel sportiello et avec gutman un
véritable festival de ministre pour
épauler dit créés sont venus défendre sa
politique devant les parlementaires
socialistes
un exercice difficile les mauvais
chiffres du chômage rendent les
socialistes morose où vindicatif
certains jospiniste très remonté contre
la politique monétariste de pierre
bérégovoy réclame un budget plus à
gauche
edith cresson qui ne céder en rien sur
un glissement du déficit budgétaire
s'est surtout employé à regonfler le
moral des troupes
la situation est difficile et nous
appartient donc de la transformer pour
que le pays puisse après une période de
morosité comme d'une façon assez ciplic
la france 1 traverse puis je disais
reprendre courage et espoir dans
l'avenir
les agriculteurs ne sont pas oubliés si
le gouvernement est prêt à ouvrir dans
les prochaines semaines une concertation
sur le monde rural
cet avertissement néanmoins avant la
grande manifestation de dimanche
quand j'entends monsieur martinez du
front national appelé à tout casser
dimanche prochain pari bien je dis que
là l'état devra faire preuve de la plus
grande vigilance fera preuve de la plus
grande vigilance mais il faut savoir que
tout débordement sera évidemment
sanctionné du plan pme pmi au plan
emploi pour les jeunes c'est en fait son
plan pour gagner les élections qu edith
cresson a présentée à des parlementaires
police et solidaire forcément solidaire
à six mois des élections la droite a
choisi l l'offensive contre le pouvoir
pour s'imposer mais à la mène en ordre
dispersé la polémique suscitée par
l'attitude de valéry giscard d'estaing
sur l'immigration la révéler elle a fait
l'objet ce soir de la réunion de l'ue pf
réunion oui mais le problème crucial de
l'immigration était très vite abordé
expédié même la réunion se poursuit
toujours en ce moment mais s'ils ont des
thèmes moins brûlant michel le merle et
dominique duchateau après le tohu bohu
de ces derniers jours à propos des
positions de giscard sur l'immigration
on aurait pu penser que les rencontres
de cet après midi serait explosive il
n'en a rien été
trois miracles le bureau de l'udf
françois lyotard absent il n'appartient
plus à cette instance les centristes
assez conciliant et sans autre souci en
tête
valéry giscard d'estaing n'a guère eu de
difficulté à faire admettre une
proposition de compromis
l'élaboration d'un texte de loi sur le
code de la nationalité
sur la base du rapport mars hollow
deuxième acte le bureau de l'upm qui
regroupe udf et rpr il n'est pas encore
terminée les amis de jacques chirac
était plutôt agacé en ayant eu le
sentiment qu'on avait remis en cause les
conclusions des états généraux de
villepinte sur l'immigration il avait
l'intention de demander des
éclaircissements mais étaient venus
autour de la table avec une idée simple
tout villepinte
rien que villepinte et sur cette base
l'accord devrait se faire sans trop de
difficulté fin donc de quatre jours de
tohu bohu
en attendant le prochain épisode
cette discrétion n'occulte pas pour
autant le problème de fond quels sont
les critères de l'identité française
la nation acceptera-t-elle d'intégrer
les fils d'étrangers qui désirent
devenir français et qui le désirent
sincèrement un jeune boxeur de
chanteloup aimerait bien connaître la
réponse sofiane à 20 ans de nationalité
algérienne il est arrivé en france à
l'âge de trois ans il apparaît comme un
exemple d'intégration
il travaille il aide les jeunes de la
cité de chanteloup les vignes
c'est aussi un sportif de très bon
niveau mais on lui refuse toujours la
nationalité française et il n'a aucun
espoir de l'obtenir avant trois ans
portrait jean marc pitte et philippe
geste là
sofiane a mis les bouchées doubles la
hargne avec laquelle il s'est entraîné
lui a fait brûler les étapes en trois
ans il est passé du statut de débutant à
celui de professionnel
aujourd'hui pourtant son élan et brisé
arrivé en france à l'âge de trois ans il
y a passé 17 ans la nationalité
française est nécessaire à la poursuite
de sa carrière
pourtant on la lui refuse on y voit le
tournoi de france de la saison dernière
le championnat de france cette année en
poids moyens et il a les possibilités de
le gagner
champion de france championne d'europe
et bien entendu un championnat du monde
bon sang la naturalisation française ne
peut rien faire et il va il est
complètement démobilisé il absolument il
a envie de se battre jusqu'à ce qu'une
comprends pas pourquoi il a un
ajournement de trois ans cet ajournement
a également provoqué la stupéfaction à
chanteloup-les-vignes sofiane il vit
depuis presque toujours la galère des
adolescents dans les cités difficiles
il l'a connue avant de la combattre
après l'overdose de certains de ses amis
il crée une association anti drogue puis
la municipalité l' embauche comme
animateur de rue ces résultats avec les
jeunes sont plus qu'encourageants
sofiane voit mal ce qu'il pourrait faire
de plus pour être considéré comme un cas
d'intégration réussie importés en france
j'ai toujours été ici vont j'ai toujours
fait ce qu'il fallait faire j'ai rempli
toutes les conditions qui avaient à
remplir j'ai leur foot j'ai un emploi
je suis mariée qu'une femme française je
suis ici comme n'importe quel autre
français
il est tout ce qu'il faut pour être un
bon citoyen de tels exemples de réussite
les enfants de chanteloup non non pas
tant sous les yeux sofiane c'est que
s'il écoute c'est surtout parce qu'il
voudrait lui ressemble et emprunter
comme lui la voie du sport pour s'en
sortir
son échec sur est aussi le leur mais
même si c'est que d'autres comptent sur
lui
les obstacles qui le rendent compte lui
donne parfois envie de raccrocher les
gants
ces divergences sur l'identité française
devienne spectaculaire mais une
unanimité semble se dessiner contre la
présence des immigrés clandestins et
contre ceux qui les emploient c'est le
sens du projet de loi adopté aujourd'hui
par le conseil des ministres
et le véritable changement dans ce texte
de loi c'est la sévérité des sanctions
pour les clandestins mais surtout pour
les employeurs des patrons qui devront
maintenant remettre un certificat
l'embaucha tout nouveau salarié
explications de marie hélène tichoux
l'entreprise qui par exemple pilote un
chantier devra vérifier que c'est tout
traitant n'emploie pas de travailleurs
clandestins
en fait quelle que soit l'activité c'est
la responsabilité du donneur d'ordre qui
est engagée les entreprises qui
emploient des travailleurs au noir
seront lourdement puni confiscation des
biens fabriqués confiscation du produit
financier
l'employeur risque de se voir interdire
pendant cinq ans d'exercer sa profession
et si l'employeur et étrangers cette
peine pourra se doubler d'une
interdiction de séjour en france le
trafic de manoeuvre se voit encore plus
sévèrement punis autre axe du projet de
loi lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine
celui qui amène des clandestins en
france risquent cinq ans de prison et
l'étranger qui détruit ses papiers pour
éviter l'expulsion sera passible de six
mois à trois ans de prison
une autre mesure a été prise par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui elles portent
sur le développement de l'apprentissage
le conseil des ministres a décidé de
débloquer 200 millions pour les centres
de formation d'apprentis
il faut dire que cet apprentissage a
mauvaise presse symbole de ce décalage
entre les jeunes sans emploi et les
centres d'apprentissage le cfa des
remous en région parisienne puis
parisienne pardon il touche l'un des
secteurs clé de l'apprentissage le
bâtiment mais les candidats vous allez
le voir sont encore trop rares ou peu
motivés agnès molinier hervé gutman
à 19 ans cédric est plombier
chauffagiste il a deux c'est ap en poche
et prépare cette année un brevet
professionnel des diplômes obtenus par
l'apprentissage une voix de cédric a
suivi après la quatrième quand il était
en situation d'échec scolaire
pour lui aujourd'hui les cours sont
réduits au minimum une semaine par mois
seulement
je suis parti de l'école et je me rends
compte maintenant que j'allais continuer
quoi mais j'étais trop jeune point que
j'avais pas la mentalité faire des
études
l'apprentissage assure à cédric un
salaire équivalent à 75% du smic
il travaille trois semaines par mois
dans une petite entreprise de plomberie
ce sont surtout elles qui emploie les
apprentis sur les quarante mille formés
chaque année
9000 salma travaille dans une société de
plus de 10 salariés
le sun ou faire rapidement une main
d'oeuvre qualifiée et il faut bien le
dire qui pour l'instant est assez
économique pour nous puisqu'il est payé
en fonction d'une portion du rink les
jeunes ne rêvent pas autre chose qu'à
une carrière dans le bâtiment
dans ce domaine la formation on assure
que la moitié des besoins de la
profession
seul espoir à l'horizon la loi de 87
elle permet d'élargir l'apprentissage à
des diplômes plus valorisants pouvoir
par la voie de l'apprentissage
maintenant devenir si vous voulez
hautement qualifiés dans le bâtiment un
passé dans ces ap un brevet
professionnel envisager demain un bac
pro voire un bts est une perspective
pour ces jeunes si vous voulez qui
redore l'image un petit peu du bâtiment
à toi tu penses qu'à des possibilités en
faisant ce métier là qu'il faut monter
assez haut
faut aller au tce du du bac
après le bac ont beaucoup de
possibilités tu as envie de faire ça
ouais j'ai le courage tienne
des jeunes comme cédric le gouvernement
on voudrait 400 milles de plus d'ici
cinq ans un pari difficile qui passe
d'abord par une revalorisation de
l'enseignement technique et restons dans
la rubrique emploi ou plutôt chômage air
france à son tour va restructurer 3000
suppressions d'emplois d'ici 93 la
disparition des avions de mark rutte et
un déménagement du siège social et de
nouvelles orientations
c'est un véritable chambardement qui
touche la compagnie aérienne martin
thibault la construction du groupe air
france va être accéléré air france est
une terre vont être fusionnées d'ici le
1er janvier 1993 la marque cutter va
disparaître pour être regroupés sous la
bannière d'air france le siège social
d'air france va être transférés à roissy
pour réunir administration et
exploitation
ces deux mesures devraient dégager un
milliard et demi d'économies chaque
année mais elles vont coûter 3000
suppressions d'emplois d'ici 1993 3000
suppressions d'emplois qu'il faudra
ajouter aux 1500 déjà programmées en 91
en outre et c'est social d'air france à
montparnasse va être vendu 1 milliard 6
un plan de restructuration qui devrait
permettre au groupe de se redresser
après le milliard de perte annoncée pour
le 1er semestre 1991
nathalie darrigrand résume les autres
événements couverts par nos rédactions
régionales
trois alpinistes espagnols au disparu
hier soir lors d'une avalanche dans une
des voies accédants mont blanc toute la
journée une trentaine de gendarmes ont
tenté de repérer les jeunes gens en
raison de mauvaises conditions
météorologiques ils ont dû arrêter leur
recherche
le préfet des bouches du rhône demande à
l'association nature et fertilité
d'interrompre ses activités de banque du
sperme selon le ministère de la santé
l'association n'a jamais sollicité ni
reçu d'agrément ministériel pierre
bernard le maire de montfermeil est
condamnée pour discrimination raciale
par le tribunal correctionnel de paris
en 88 et 89 il a des mots fusent et
d'inscrire des enfants immigrés dans une
école maternelle de sa commune
il devra verser 20 mille francs d'amendé
la nappe de pollution a touché ce matin
le littoral à ramatuelle
les premiers résidus se sont déposés sur
deux plages varoises quelques traces
sont même apparus sur l'une des plages
de saint-tropez
mais l'essentiel de la plaque dérive
encore au large du cap camarat et l'on
va revoir roger knobelspiess mais cette
fois à l'écran jean pierre mocky offre
un rôle à l'ancien détenu
moi qui aime une chose par dessus tous
par dessus tout étonné même choqué son
dernier film en tournage en ce moment
dans la région de massy réussira
sûrement
il s'appelle ville à vendre et il réunit
des acteurs aussi brillante différents
michel serrault jacqueline maillan
richard bohringer ou encore eddy
mitchell de nancy joël barre si
fascination pour les quelque 500
figurants lorrain présent sur le
tournage ils ont à leurs côtés un
casting exceptionnel bohringer cero eddy
mitchell valérie mairesse
sans oublier l'enfant du pays cob
novembre le personnage qui nous
proposait qui est inquiétant passez moi
l'expression un fruit merde
j'aime assez bien ces personnages qui
essaye de savoir ce qui se passe
derrière les apparences et
puis c'est vrai que les partenaires que
j'ai appris dont j'ai appris qu'il
faisait partie du film était prestigieux
nobel peace profite de cette météo pour
entrer en scène libéré en out 90 après
26 ans de prison grâce à vos qui il
tente de se réinsérer en tant que
comédien comme les gamins bohringer ou
autres mickey rourke un petit rôle
excellent qui en appelle d'autres
moi j'espère un vrai rôle un rôle qui
soit pas celui d'un plus belles pistes
pourfendeur elle ne put ville du blocage
mais le nombre ou d'un homme qui s'est
battu pendant 26 ans et et qui peut
faire passer d'un à l'écran autre chose
c'est-à-dire ma résistance et aider mon
refus et je peux transformer tout ça on
je parle en émotions bouleversement ce
qu'apple est un acte l'acteur du
bouleversement avec villa vendre mots
qui tire un homme du pétrin
parallèlement il immortalise ce site de
job dans quinze jours la dynamite en
aura eu raison
je vous rappelle l'information de la
soirée des manifestations violentes se
déroule à bucarest elles ont fait un
mort un civil soir 300 à 22h30 présenté
par mark coxon fait le temps 7 à 20
heures avec florence klein bonsoir à
demain 19h pour ça